would you guys support uh neuralink
prisons no I don't think I think real
life is real life and you have to be
punished in real life yeah I do too it's
like waking up from a dream you know
it'll affect you for a day perhaps I
also just don't trust neuralink at all
and so there's a level of I don't feel
like I can in good faith put someone in
nurlink prison if I also don't trust
nurlink at all I will let Elon
experiment on bad people perhaps let's
say you got somebody like that was that
was there's one group that tried that
there's Dad let's say you got somebody
who uh he's 20 years old and him and his
buddies go into a bodega and armed
robbery steal from the store clerk smash
everything up take all his money ransack
the place and then leave they get caught
later and he gets sentenced to four
years in prison for the armed robbery
his sentence is he will be placed in a
neuralink where he will wake up with the
memories of of a store clerk owner and
none of his past life and he will
experience having his life savings and
life destroyed in this moment and then
after that moment he wakes up realizing
what he did and how they felt isn't that
kind of like what they were doing in
Clockwork Orange when they had the guy's
eyes kept open and they're showing him
all the uh yeah but like actually having
him experience the life of you're a guy
who saved up oh you know he's like I'm
working really hard my my my my wife is
sick I need to make money and then yeah
you come in Smash something and destroy
it
and then they leave and you experience
all of that suffering I guess one of the
things that brings up for me is the idea
like in the neural link are you able to
program someone's emotions because like
if you don't feel the guilt or if you
don't feel empathy really then going
into someone else's life and suffering
like would you experience the you force
them through that experience and it's
monitored and measured what if they wake
up really worried about the amount of
power who's controlling the neuralink
that would be yeah I'm just anti
neuralink I think across the board uh
about only as uh only for the left yeah
only for people they want it like what
if the prisoners are like okay you can
do this one or you can go into the
neural link like do we want their like
lethal injection versus n hypox we want
there to be options for people to choose
how they're punished what if we just say
we're going to we're we're going to send
you like you committed a crime you can
go to prison regular real life prison
for like Okay so this it's a serious
crime
it's a negligent homicide you were
drinking and driving you killed two kids
you're going to get 10 years because
it's your it's your like third DUI you
weren't supp you didn't have a license
you're you're not someone who is like
trying to go out and kill but you've
shown a pattern of behavior and they say
here what we're going to do we're lock
lock you up for 15 years 20 years or
noral link for life but neural link
happiness you can go into this machine
we remove you from society because
you're a danger to society you will live
a normal happy life where you will feel
good good and you will cause no harm to
anybody I guess that's the other
question like is imprisonment about
separating people from the population or
is it about Rehabilitation because there
are other countries that have different
feelings about this and I think it would
be hard to know it's supposed to in the
United States the purpose of prison is
to uh unite gang members and Harden them
to the worst criminals until there's a
lock down and then you release them all
so the crime they keep their populations
down it's just a calling Method Man
that's all it is but Shane what if one
day you're like on your deathbed your
family's all around you and then you're
like thank you for such a a good life
and they're like we love you we love you
and then you wake up and you're like
some 26-year-old gang banger who like
shot who shot an author who wrote weird
sci-fi mystery no I I would be extremely
depressed I would if to wake up and and
not have that family well how do you
wake up man true but think about like
you guys have you ever watch the Rick
and Morty episode where uh summer is in
the car and Rick is like protect summer
and
it shoots a guy in the SP at first it
slices a guy into cubes and she screams
like don't do don't kill people so then
it paralyzes the next guy and she's like
stop hurting people so then when the
police show up it it
genetically clones the son of one of the
police officers and the child comes out
and he's like Daddy and he's like oh my
God and he HTS his son but then his
son's like don't hurt the car dad he's
like what and then the kid melts and
he's screaming like think about the kind
of torture you could do to people with a
neuralink where you give them a child
and then force them to to live full
neurolink reality of watching their
child be murdered in front of them it
also depends on the degree to which
these people can or have a capacity for
emotion cuz some of these psychoth I
don't know if it would work on them so
minute ago we were saying like you can
make them feel some emotions or whatever
but I don't think that's the point the
point is to get the person to feel those
emotions but then you have to get you
get the idea of yeah whether they can
feel those or if they're capable of
feeling it yeah would like Hannah
mentioned earlier are you able to
control their emotions or you just try
to manipulate them well you but like you
you could theoretically make I I think
at the point of neuralink you can make
them feel things like if we're talking
about read write physical pain emotional
pain emotional everything like if we can
write to the brain enough to where they
can experience things you could force
emotional sens that's what I'm curious
about because like again I would never
be a for neurolink I don't think I could
ever be convinced but with like you can
make someone feel something but it is
enough to rewire the the way their brain
works right if you had a sociopath is
neuralink going to be able to to make
them experience enough to make them have
empathy like if you're hardwired to to
function a certain way but maybe you
just use the neuralink to reprogram his
brain to be virtuous but that's that's
the point no but yes that's the point
hey we're going to take out the murder
part care but this is this is the point
right the point is when so imagine the
sci-fi movie a guy is living a life and
he experiences the death of his
girlfriend and he starts an organization
to fight drunk driving and he becomes an
old man and then you know like a young
woman comes in and just I just want to
let you know that you know you really
helped my dad and the organization you
did blah blah blah I turned his
alcoholism around and he's like thank
you so much and then on his deathbed
he's got you know his loved ones around
them are like you stopped so many drunk
drivers and then he wakes up as a
23-year-old who killed two people in a
drunk driving accident and he's
immediately like we can never allow
drunk driving ever again oh my God and
then completely abandons it could work
on some and it might not work on others
that's why I think it's it's unrel
but hold on for the sociopaths who can't
feel emotional pain you just simulate
them being fled alive over and over
again we'll do a we need a neural link
for unit 7:30 or whatever it wasit 371
731 whatever it is in Japan uh yeah so
this is why I'm trying to talk to Elon
about the nuring so we can get answers
to these questions one day one day he'll
respond yeah I don't know man there's a
whole lot of power for the for the
person pushing the buttons the thing
about n is there's beautiful things
about what he talks about Elon talking
about now with fixing epilepsy
or exactly but these these things we're
talking about that are I don't think
that far away from what nurlink is
capable of doing I I'm really curious do
you think you think you be use for
people that have like that have like
psychological uh like uh what's the word
I guess antisocial disorders you think
they neurod
Divergence hey neurer I had a brain
injury I'm all right guys I have real
brain damage okay guys someone who has a
personality stop claiming that you're
special
always want to be the victim I'm from
South Africa I lived abroad I Had a
Brain
Injury search I get it I get it you're
very very
special you're all very special now go
home uh no but the thing is like could
it could it cure a personality disorder
yeah that's what I'm saying like could
someone murder Mur someone could hack it
and someone would program what
personality to you well someone someone
posted this uh there was a meme actually
I wonder I wonder if I can find it uh it
was basically like some guys being
annoying on the train so they hack his
neuralink to make him trans W that's why
to give him like to give him gender
dysphoria yeah terrifying no thank you
yeah we we can't have that future Tim
I'm sure you saw um in ghost in the show
uh and like a lot of the different stuff
they talk about there they would hack
people literally because if anyone knows
the anime they have people in there that
are cyborgs and they would literally
hack the Cyborg and make them one of the
opening scenes this guy doesn't know
what he's doing he thinks he has this
whole program life of like 30 years in
reality he just got hacked this morning
and he thinks he's living out this whole
like grand scheme and he's a wife and
kids and stuff but really it's not even
real it's just fake memory is this what
dreams are people just hacking Us in the
simulation it I mean could be who knows
man no I don't buy dreams are when you
log out and you're out yeah you log out
like in westw World there is no W
predict PRK yeah no no thank you did you
like West world did you watch it I
watched the first season I think like
most
people what happened Jesse from breaking
bad got really depressed and I was like
yeah the first season of Westworld was
amazing I was so I binged it and then at
second season I was like this is trash
first season is is great but I I referen
that a lot talking when we talk about
like NPCs because the the robots in
westw World couldn't see a door so you
knew they couldn't see a door they're a
robot and when you talk about NPCs and
the alternate reality there and they
don't see our reality that's they're the
robots you know so I I just look at that
it's like a test for vampires I can't
see their reflection and what if we're
all NPCs and there are weird you know
8ot tall green people who walk around
like just laughing and watching the show
and they're like ah this is so fun yeah
I guess there's a degree of relativism
to NPCs cuz we would be then to the
shadow beings or the the gray aliens
that are walking Among Us Shadow yeah
they're here right now they're in that
chair yeah they're just like they're
they're watching uh like it's like like
it's like a movie yeah I'm just like
look at these guys talking about these
things look at these guys can they have
free
speech Free Will how it's so horrible
like they all think they're going to
make millions there's some fat green
skinned thing sitting next to its fat
green skinned roommate eating popcorn
being like it's really funny that
they're debating Free Speech but they're
all programmed
so wait till they hit the next level and
we upgrade this into where wait until we
see what we do with Joe Rogan next yeah
yeah they're really enjoying their
corpse president so funny I mean it it
certainly doesn't feel like we're in the
in in life how crazy everything is it's
just like you know people want to look
for miracles like well Donald Trump
being president doesn't seem like real
life nobody thought it was possible and
here he is so it's I don't know what you
think Miracles are supposed to look like
but all of the crazy stuff that we've
seen over the past few years it really
does feel like someone wrote this yeah I
I think I don't believe we're in a
simulation I believe that there is a
false reality put on top of this Reality
by the corporate press by the
bureaucrats oh that's true and they keep
selling it and people buy into that
world which is basically like being a
simulation which is why we feel like
we're in an alternate reality from the
people on the left you think Trump is
real think I st believing in Trump when
I was
12 thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net